well you are watching this video so you
like numbers
and i like numbers since i was very
little and one particular sequence i
really loved was
was powers of two so let's start with
one right one is two to power zero so it
has to be here and then we have two
4 8 16 32 and then we keep on going 128
256 5 1 12 1 over 2 4 2 over 4 8. oops
we are and out of space well let me make
things easier and only concentrate on
the first digit of this guys we keep
one two four eight and then we only
keep one
three six
one two
and five
one
two and so on so uh so let's collect all
this data and put this all together and
that's what we get here is the sequence
of numbers i'm going to talk about let's
look at it the stretch one two four
eight one three six one two five which
we had here let me
mark it like this and let me see the
same stretch and then we see the same
stretch very curious
and one more time
and we try to do it one more time but
then there is a little seven and we have
a box here
and here we have two things
which are different
and if we keep on going
it happens to be absolutely the same
as this one
but if we if we're here
something else
happens we have an extra six which
wasn't there before so the question is
what uh
what is going to happen in the long run
we have a huge huge huge number of these
guys and maybe maybe we can run a little
experiment and count how many ones how
many twos how many threes and so on so
let's have a little table one two three
four five six seven
eight
nine so in the first
stage we have three dots here
because there are three ones
two dots because we have two twos and
then we have a three and the four and
the five and the six eight so seven is
missing nine is missing but then
something else starts
going on this this is going to change
the question i want to ask is suppose
you have a billion digits then uh do we
have more sevens than eight or maybe
more eights than sevens uh what about
six or fives so how to actually make
sense of it so will will the sevens and
nines make a comeback will someone break
away and have a lead exactly we'll have
quite a few eights here and sevens or
nines are trailing behind but maybe
we'll spring
ahead and another question is uh right
we have a sequence which seemed to be
periodic
we have this pattern going on what if in
the long long long run we'll have
another pattern and it will start go on
forever
well first of all let me state the
question in mathematicians when they
state the questions they sometimes use
some notation
right you probably got used to it
because you watched
100 videos
of this channel already so so let me
let me talk about talking about
let me call it a sub n
n is a natural number and a sub n
is
the first
digit of 2 to the n here we have a sub 0
and then a sub 1 and a sub 4. sorry f
sub 2 is up 3 and so on
okay
and then
we look we take
very big natural number n and look at
the number of
of little n say between 0 and
n
such that
this a sub n
is equal to k
where this k could be one or two or
three or four or nine okay so what what
is it if n is very big and
specifically let me
take this number and divide by n and
this is going to be the probability you
hit
2 if k is 2 or 4 case 4.
okay so out of these numbers what is the
proportion of the ones that have a value
k so you have this huge system huge
sequence that we saw already and
we can count the number of ones and
that's what i did over there
or twos or threes and what is going to
happen if we increase the length of the
sequence mathematicians usually say
where does it go to if
n goes to infinity
which means take a very
and here k
is fixed so for example k could be one
or two or three so that's a question you
can ask
if you look at the sequence and
some of you have seen a video about the
benford law and that's the answer
amazingly so you already know the answer
so what happens is that you have more
ones than twos more twos than threes
more threes than fours even here with
our sevens and those that's right
eventually
seven catches up and
starts growing and it beats eight and
this uh the answer that we have those
numbers
which is logarithm base 10 of 1 plus
1 over k which is exactly the ones
appearing in benford's law this log 10
of 1 over k what does it mean it means
that
the number of all the proportion of ones
eventually goes to 30.1
well approximately and uh here we have
17.6 percent and here we have 12.5 and
fours get 9.7 and here we have
approximately
it's not exact figure it's approximate
and here we have 6.7 5.8 5.1 and then
4.6 so it gets smaller and smaller
obviously you're not surprised by this
because you're a mathematician but well
i would say i was surprised by this
event
initially when
it turned out to be the case but then
there's a proof or some surprises
like so many of our videos this was
recorded at the mathematical sciences
research institute
in berkeley california to see more from
this interview including some more proof
there's a link on the screen and also in
the video description and you can also
watch our previous video on benford's
law the property goes up and up and up
through the thousands
and then down through the 2000s 3500